welcome back to my special edition with
astrophysicist and author Neil deGrasse
Tyson His Brilliant new book Starry
Messenger Cosmic perspectives on
civilization is a much needed Clarion
call for a belief in science and facts
that old trick to try and get through
the world's complexities
um Neil let's talk about gender gender
is probably the most divisive theme in
the world right now it's almost like you
can't even talk about it without people
losing their minds and I guess at the
center of it is this core belief which
many put forward that there is a
biological science towards sex and then
there is gender and that is an identity
issue which is separate to sex and
biology what is your view of this and
why has it got so toxic and what is the
way through this debate
yeah so I think I have some insights
there brought to you by how we end up
classifying things in the universe in
the universe very few things are
discreet in what they are there's in
almost all cases a Continuum between one
kind of object and another now it's hard
to have conversations about continua so
you you divide it up into as many
categories as is sensible and then you
then you
then you have a way to discuss what's
going on in the universe with others so
here we have human beings where let's go
back to the the bio part of this where
you have the chromosomes x x y there's
intersex where one of the chromosomes is
doubled up no one is arguing that just
give that to the biologists and you can
call that uh what sex is it male sex or
female sex I don't have a problem with
that what I do know is that in the real
world
in the real world
in a free country where because I
remembered some document that said the
pursuit of happiness
um it seems to me Freedom which is so
heavily championed in the west uh is
accompanied by a Pursuit of Happiness
okay
that's foundational to what I'm about to
say
so we all know growing up that in the
classroom every year there were girls
who were a little more tomboyish in fact
we probably tomboy who came up with that
word they're really Tom girls right a
tomcat is a boy cat a tom girl would be
a sort of a boy girl right I don't know
where tomboy came from but they were Tom
girls they didn't wear skirts they
wanted to play in the mud with the boys
we know they existed they were boys that
were slightly effeminate relative to the
others we know they existed and so but
we had words for them they were
ridiculed whatever we live in a time now
where people are emboldened to say you
know today I feel
part female and part male all right so
today in fact I will be neutral to you I
will be androgynous
but you know something if you're trained
in this you got to be a or b you got to
be a boy you got to be a girl you know
what you're doing you're taking your
inability of your human Mind by the way
this is true for all human Minds because
we got to categorize we always have to
categorize all right it makes it easier
to think about it but the in the end
it's just lazy all right so you say boy
or girl are you a boy or a girl and then
someone is androgynous and it makes you
feel uncomfortable but just because you
feel uncomfortable does that give you
the right to come back to a person who's
expressing their freedom of self it
doesn't but I would say right but what I
would say to this here's where it gets
more complicated take the issue of
transgender athletes in women's sport
for example okay no no I got two more
sentences and I'll jump right into that
okay I just want to set up to set the
table here I'm setting the table where
okay that
if J if we allow gender to appear on a
spectrum gender expression to appear on
a spectrum
as is apparently the case in the real
world where people have the freedom to
do so
than for you to put your limited
capacity to think on a spectrum in a law
that inhibits the freedom of others
that's not a free country
okay so now take it to the next step
where do you want to take that well what
I want to take you to is I I don't
disagree with that I think in a free
country you should be allowed to
identify whatever you hell you want to
identify it's fine I've got no problem
with that okay so now where are you
taking it so what I'm taking it I'm
taking you specifically to say the issue
of transgender athletes in women's sport
which I think has in an attempt to
provide fairness and equality for Trans
athletes in women's sport it doesn't
apply the other way in men's sport in
women's sport it's created a new
inequality and unfairness where you have
trans women born with Superior powerful
male biological bodies who are beginning
to beat women with comfortable ease in
many sports and yet they were very
unsuccessful comparatively when they
competed against other biological males
as they were before they transitioned so
my my question I guess there is isn't
that a clear case where science has to
be the understanding Factor because if
you remove that from this equation then
you end up with gender-neutral Olympics
and women don't ever win Olympic medal
again
well there are certain events that the
men like like the uneven bars you won't
find men on the uneven Parts it doesn't
work
okay uh but my point being there are
reasons why we divide the sexes in sport
is my point and the moment you start
allowing of gender identity to to
overcome biology I see there's a problem
Okay so
all that means is we are on a frontier
that has not been previously breached
which is what do you do in a sport where
now there's an inherent
um advantage or disadvantage based on
the rules that existed for that sport
whereas previously those advantages or
disadvantages didn't exist so this is
not complicated
in high school in college and a little
bit of graduate school
I wrestled okay I was Captain of my high
school wrestling team and undefeated
uh I weighed in high school 190 pounds
uh do I wrestle the 125 pounder no that
would be unfair because I'm 65 pounds
heavier twice as strong and maybe even
faster so they set up a rule I only
wrestle people my weight wrestling has
10 weight categories
to make it an interesting contest okay
so let me just make this up now just as
a as a starter point
uh the transgenderism usually involves
hormone uh readjustments okay
testosterone estrogen and so we can
imagine a future of sports where you're
not contesting men against women
you're contesting people in certain
brackets of hormone levels
and
why not because it doesn't work
I hesitate to lecture you about science
a professor Neil deGrasse Tyson I really
do but I'll tell you why not because
what they've they've already tried to do
this they've already tried to reduce
hormone levels what it doesn't do that
process is reduce body mass or strength
biology
right if you went through puberty as a
male yes and then transitioned
afterwards right then you you'll have a
bigger strong typically bigger strong
that's what I just think he's done I
don't have a transphobic bone in mind
let's get there I'm getting there
for Trans athletes but there's a big
butt here I think I I
I'm working my way up to that so so one
possibility like I said I'm just making
this up on the supply is you have
hormone categories if that does not
solve the problem or to the extent that
it doesn't then you put in other rules
that separate who's competing with whom
like I said we do this all the time
right all right and by the way are you
going to go to Michael Phelps and say
you're genetically taller and we have a
floppier I don't know if all of this is
true but some of it is true you have
floppier ankles and webbed fingers and
so we're not going to compete you in
this race because you'll have an
advantage that other people don't we
don't do that do we in fact when you
really analyze it practically every gold
medal record-setting Olympic athlete has
some genetic thing going on in them that
other people they do but my response
okay my response to that would be I
think Serena Williams has been on record
as saying that she would lose to the top
1000 male real tennis players so my
point
999 best in the world as a male tennis
player and become immediately if you
decided to identify as a woman the
greatest woman tennis player of all time
is that fair I don't think it is okay so
now watch so watch so it turns out if
and I've done this but others have done
it as well but I did it for myself to
know it if you look at world records
from world-class athletes uh let's say
track and field the hundred meters men
are about 10 times 10 faster uh 200
meters 10 it fluctuates but on average
it's about the marathon the men do it
about 10 faster okay and you look at
reflexes it's about 10 percent faster
the way you have the biggest differences
in weightlifting but for Speed and
reflexes it's about 10 faster so if you
wanted to find out where the top women's
athlete would land among men you look at
serving speeds for example because
that's how fast you can bring the racket
to the ball and find the point where the
women's serving speeds match up with the
men's serving speeds okay and then
that's where you would land in the world
rankings what I will tell you is people
pay to watch sports not for how good the
athlete is they watch sports for how
good the contest is
but let's remind ourselves of this if if
we only watched Sports for the greatest
of athletes you would never watch
college football never because the the
worst NFL that National in the London
audience here National Football League
the worst National Football League team
there ever was
could wipe their ass with the best
college team there ever was right
because everyone in the professions each
one of them was the best in their
college okay so but we love watching
college football why because the contest
is equal and you don't know who's going
to win in advance if you was going to
win in advance you wouldn't that would
be that would be even if it was the best
to bring this this bit of the interview
to I think enclosure I would say I I get
that completely but the most important
thing as a sports fan is you want to get
a sense it's a fair playing field that I
think is really the Crux so what you do
is in in the future what you would do is
it so if the hormone levels categories
don't work then there are other
categories reflex categories okay have
people compete in reflex categories I
would love that okay then the people
with pretty slow reflexes they'll have a
different strategies and how they would
win and and group them together by the
way in chess tournaments your chess
rating
put you in a category where you only
compete with other people in that rating
you don't compete against people where
you beat them in 10 moves so so we are
still on at the dawn of how we will or
should organize the future of sports in
recognition of the gender spectrum and
we just have to put some creativity
behind it I don't see any problem with
it that's why I never wrestled 120 pound
person I would love to see that would
have been quite entertaining
now when we come back in the Octagon you
pay to see that I've actually seen some
very very skillful 120 pound wrestlers
it wouldn't be a given sometimes the big
guys go down even you Neil deGrasse
Dyson uh undefeated very impressive by
the way undefeated let's take a note in
high school in high school